Mark: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and this is Bob and Wade!
*Wade bursts into laughter*
Mark: What?
Wade: *laughing* That was perfectly in sync!
Mark: Well, good! Then why'd you laugh?
Mark: I don't know. What is he laughing at ?
Bob:I think he is just laughing 'cause we were both just like *waves.*
*laughter*
Mark: Just like my two bodyguards here are back from Cincinnati.
Mark: Except for you.
*Wade snickers*
Bob: That's not...
Mark: That's not where you're from, no.
Wade: One of us is back from Cincinnati.
Mark: Rally.
Bob: That's not how you say it.
Mark: Raleigh?
Bob: Yeah, that's the one.
Mark: Nevada.
Wade: Checkers, they call it checkers.
Bob: Nevada?
Mark: Nah-vada.
Wade: It's checkers in the south
Bob: No!
Mark: No, I'm saying like when you pronounce "nev-oughta."
Mark: People get mad.
Wade: Yeah, when you say "Rally"
you pronounce it "Nevahda."
*laughter*
Mark: You know, "Rally". Nevada.
Bob: Sure.
Mark: Anyway. Hello.
Mark: Welcome to the Monday vlog.
Mark: It's late, but then again,
Mark: I said it was gonna be late,
Mark: because I was picking up these goofs at the airport.
Mark: They just flew in
Mark: for th... *spitting sounds*
Mark: So they just flew in, from,
*Bob snorts*
Mark: wherever they came from.
Wade: Raleigh
Mark: Raleigh
Bob: Nevada
Mark: and Cincinnati, to do videos with us,
Mark: here, for a full week!
Mark: Not a full week, it's like 4 days.
Bob: Yeah.
Wade: It's most of a week.
Mark: It's MOST of a week.
Mark: It's the most productive cycle of the week.
Mark: We've got a whole list of stuff that we're gonna be doing all week long
and that includes us going out and finding you guys
through various part of Los Angeles.
Mark: So we're gonna be in-
Wade: That's cool !
Mark: various places all Wednesday long.
Mark: We're gonna be going to
a whole bunch of different places.
Mark: We're gonna try to get to...
Wade: Like "Rally"
Mark: Ah, no !
Mark: That's not in Los Angeles.
Bob: That's...
Wade: Oh that's right.
Mark: That's in Nevada.
Bob: You gotta let the joke go Wade.
Mark: Yeah, exactly.
Bob: We're actually talking about different locations now.
Mark: You know I- in improv, it's called a call back
Wade: Yeah!
Mark: It's supposed to be extra funny when
Mark: you call back something that occured from- ...
Bob: Yeah, the longer you let it wait though
Bob: the funnier the call back is
Mark: Ohhhh...
Wade: Ok I'll wait until the end and I'll say "Rally" again.
Bob: You can't just right for it
Bob: Yeah. Just, last word.
Mark: 'Cause definitely "Rally" was the funniest thing we've said in the past few...
Mmmm, minutes...
(laughters)
Bob: Mmmmmm.
Wade: Mmmmmm minutes.
Mark: Ew, god.
Mark: There's a lot of fluids being exchanged here and I don't much appreciate it.
Mark: Any-
Bob: This side of the couch is dry.
Bob: I don't know what you guys are doing.
Mark: Alright, so anyway we're off topic here.
Mark: Thank you guys so much for being patient on this vlog.
Uh, we have had so many things in planning for this week-
and we are ready to get going on videos.
Videos are gonna be regular after this one but-
in, when- when it comes to next week,
when we finally have all the stuff recorded
and we're getting everything done,
it's gonna be super fun with lots of new types of videos.
Not really.
Same old shit.
We're nothing original.
Aaaaaaahnnd- *Wade giggles*
Wade: Raleigh
Mark: I'm buil- SHUT-!
*laughter*
Mark: -UP!
Bob: See? See? You waited and it was funnier !
Wade: I know!
Mark: Shut up! Shut up!
Mark: So now we're gonna continue this vlog.
I've nothing else to say.
Wade: Raleigh
Mark: Raleigh
Mark: What do you mean ? What are you doing ?
Bob: Tyler's behind the camera.
Bob: Stretch it out!
Mark: *laughing* Stretch it out !
Bob: We've got time to fill !
Mark: We gotta fill 10 minutes!
Mark: We gotta do this!
Tyler: (off camera) Talk about all the stuff that you're gonna be doing...
Mark: Fuck you!
Mark: What is everyone always telling me,
Mark: "Oh don't spoil the surprise!"
Mark: And you can't even say it's not!
Tyler: (offscreen) Not everything!
Mark: 'Cause Yesterday
Mark: I got lectured
Mark: for spoiling the surprise.
*Bob laughs*
Tyler: (offscreen) I didn't start that! *Bob laughs*
Tyler: I didn't start it!
Mark: Well, it doesn't matter! *Bob keeps laughing*
Mark: Because everyone said
*Bob continues laughing*
Mark: that I was spoiling the surprise!
Wade: Stop saying things with S's and P's!
Mark: Alright Bob.
Bob: I like how you yell that way and you're looking me and you're like
*Mark laughs*
Bob: "Eh"
Mark: 'Cause there's more people to yell at over there.
Mark: Here it's all nice.
Mark: Got Bob, Cathryn and Ethan.
Mark: Hi, Ethan!
Ethan (off-screen): Hi.
Wade: There's technically more people over there to yell at.
Mark: No, no... No no.
Bob: But he doesn't wanna yell at them
Bob: -is what he's saying.
Mark: No, no, no, no
Mark: We're off topic again! Hi, my,
Wade: Raleigh!
Mark: -name is Markiplier, and we're here to tell you
about this fun-filled week that I'm about to spoil for all of you.
Mark: N-you aren't gunna see this 'til next week!
Mark: *gurgling noises* OOPS! I, d-uh, uh
Mark: *gibberish* J-just, uh uh, tomorrow
Mark: Tonight! We're gunna do..
*Wade snickers*
...let's plays.
Mark: Tomorrow... We're gunna do
challenges. Wednesday..
Mark: we're gunna do...
Bob: *interrupting* Fan interactions.
Mark: Fan stuff!
*Bob laughs again*
Mark: I said that! Wait, I said that! I said
Mark: Wednesday we're all gunna be doin the fan stuff!
Mark: I already said this! We know exactly
what we're gonna be doing,
when we're gonna be doing it.
Mark: So be on the lookout, we're gunna TELL you guys
about it, WHEN we're ready on
Wednesday. Be on the lookout, we're gonna be there!
Mark: This is very threatening, maybe I should-
Mark: The President- [I'm unable to tell what Bob says 'cause of Wade]
Wade: WE'RE GONNA BE THERE, YOU'RE GONNA BE THERE!
Mark: The president:
Mark, imitating President Obama: We're.......gonna be there.
Mark: ..We're gonna meet you guys-
Wade: The President Shatner?? *giggles*
Bob: That was like an Obama cadence.
Mark, normal: That was Obama.
Wade: Oh
Wade, trying to mimic Mark's imitation: We're... gonna be there.
Mark: That's not what I did at all!
Bob: That's Obama.
Mark: We're gonna bE theRE.
Wade: We're gonna be there.
Mark, imitating Arnold Schwarzenegger: I'm- We're gonna be there.
Mark, still imitating: We're gonna be everywhere.
Mark (normal): This is all irrelevant
to exactly to the point that I'm trying to make
is that I'm literally just filling time.
I've nothing else of substance to say
so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
it's gonna be a fun week, we've got the whole gang here.
We've got a whole week full of stuff to do,
it's gonna be super exciting.
And I can't wait to show you guys and I'm super-
like, incredibly thankful that my friends are out here again.
Just to be serious, like-
I really do miss you guys.
Bob: Aw.
Mark: On a day to day basis and-
Bob: Same.
Mark: -we don't play games enough.
Bob: No, we don't.
Mark: And I miss you guys dearly.
Wade: That is true [Wade bein' a lil too quiet on the true]
Mark: Every second that you're not here.
Mark: So anyway,
Wade: Oh.
Mark: I just wanted to say that you guys are awesome.
Wade: I forgive you for spitting on me now.
Mark: You're welcome.
Mark: I mean, there's gonna be a lot more spit comin'.
*giggles* *gibberish* Wade did-what'd *laughs again*
*Laughter as wade contemplates what Mark just said*
*Bob still laughing* Mark: So, Bob, would you like to say anything before we go?
Bob: Oh, god. Put me on the spot, why don't ya?
Mark: Yes
Bob: All the exact same things that Mark
had said eh-but more eloquently said.
Mark: That's probably for the best
Wade: Raleigh]
Bob: It uh-It does.. I will say
being in LA is pretty exciting, 'cause we were all here
before for once previously.
Mark: Yeah
Bob: That was a long time ago.
Wase: Was that only once we-
Mark: The three of us
Bob: The one time all three of us had been here.
*to Tyler* not you. You're not on the camera.
if you're not on camera. I don-You're not even a person to me right now!
*Mark nervously laughs* Bob: Except for those guys, they're cool.
Mark: Oh yeah, these guys are cool.
Bob: Just Tyler's not a person.*laughter*
Bob: Anyway, what was I saying?
Mark: Uh
Mark: You were being grateful and thankful for friendship .
Bob: Ohh yeah.
Bob: Fuck Tyler.
*Wade snorts and Mark laughs*
Mark: But yeah.
Bob: I think, I think the point of what I was saying was fuck Tyler.
Bob: Sorry, Tyler.
Mark: But it, it is incredible that the three of us together in LA.
Mark: Hasn't happened in years.
Mark: Literally years.
Wade: Wow.
Bob: Yeah. Wade: That's depressing.
Mark: Over two years now?
Bob: It w- The only time I ever came our here was like, right after you've had first moved out.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: So two, almost three years ago?
Mark: I w- yeah, almost three years. Bob: Something like that?
Mark: So at least two years ago.
Mark: But-
Wade: Whenever Markiplier's Magic Touch came out.
Bob: Yeah!
Mark: Yeah, my god that was it!
Mark: holy shit!
Bob: I can't believe everyone didn't just start grabbing me when I walked in. the house today
[I would pay to see that xD]
Wade: Well, I tried.
Mark: I mean y'know we, we- it was like the car 'cause I'd- *awkward hang gestures*
Bob: Whatever.
Mark: Anyway, so it's gonna be an awesome time.
Mark: We've got all of us here just to have fun.
Mark: And have fun with you guys, and to make fun videos for you all to enjoy.
Mark: So look forward to what's coming soon!
Mark: Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always..
Mark: We'll see you, IN the next video.
Mark: BUH-BYEE!
*all waving*
Mark (while laughing): Oh, wait, Wade did you wanna say anything?
*lots, lots of laughter*
Mark (embarrassed): OH, I totally forgot, OH, NOO!
*laughter from off-camera*
Mark: OH, NOOO!
Mark: WADE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY SOMETHING?
*laughter*
Wade: I'm good.
Mark: You're good?
Wade: Ya..
Bob: Cu-
Wade: I can't top Bob's eloquence.
Mark: Okay, alright, the eloquent Bob cannot be topped.
Mark: I'm sorry.
*laughter*
Mark: Ooohhhh..
Mark: Byyyeeee.
Wade: FRIENDSHIP
*laughter*
Mark: FRIEENDS.
*more laughter*